والاسلحة ها هو العالم يقول ان
حرب اوكرانيا لا زالت في البداية
البشت العربي يلقى رواجا غير
مسبوق لدى شعب الارجنتين.
لتعلنها روسيا دون سابق انذار
العملية العسكرية اقتربت من
يمكن القيام به لمصلحة البلاد هو
محاربة التضخم لتؤكد الحكومة
اي مشاورات سابقة. بعد ان ارتداه
ميسي خلال رفعه لكأس العالم.
البريطانية ان نحو الف ومائتي
عنصر من الجيش سيحلون مكان موظفي
كانوا قد القوها على
الفلسطينيين. يا لضعف قلوبكم
وجبنكم. ليبيا ترفض اعلان مصر
ترسيم الحدود البحرية معها دون
القطريين. في خطوة معارضة للغرب
ها هي تشيلي تحرج الغرب وتنوي
بارتدائهم له ورسم الجداريات.
فيا لها من حركة ذكية من
التي تجتاح البلاد. مشيرا الى ان
الاوضاع باتت صعبة وان افضل ما
فتح سفارتها في الاراضي
الفلسطينية. ومن اصوات المدافع
الاسعاف. لحظات صعبة عاشها جنود
الاحتلال بعد اعادة مسيلة للدموع
قال انه مستاء من الفوضى التي
سببتها موجة الاضرابات العمالية
الرابحة. الرئيس التركي يسلك
جميع السبل ما يهدد تارة ويعود
يترك اوكرانيا ليتوجه الى انقرة.
الاحداث والتطورات. رئيس الوزراء
ابوابها لان الموظفين مرضى ومعظم
المدارس اغلقت كما تراجع استخدام
لاستيعاب اعداد المرضى المصابين.
والصيدليات تشكو من نفد مخزونات
ليبشر تارة اخرى. ها هو ينتقد
التجاهل الدولي للازمة السورية
البرد والحمى عدد منها لا يسمح
بدخول العملاء. الشركات تغلق
وسائل النقل العام. هناك طلبت
واشنطن الصين بالشفافية بشأن
ننسى ان البحر الاسود يطل على
حدود بوتين البحري. لا نريد ان
عدم ايجاد حل للاجئين. ومن جانب
اخر ها هو يتهم اليونان بالتعامل
الاصابات بفيروس كورونا المتحول
الجديد لتواجه المستشفيات صعوبات
تفشي الفيروس معلنة استعدادها
لمساعدة الصينيين في اللقاحات
على ما وصفه باستفزازات امريكية
وتايوانية ما ذنب السمك في البحر
الصين الى حربها المشتعلة في
الداخل. تسونامي كورونا يضرب
للشعب التركي تتعلق باكتشاف جديد
للغاز في البحر الاسود. اذا فلا
مع اللاجئين ريقة وحشية ليعلن
هنا خلال افتتاح مشاريع في ارض
يشكل خطرا على استقرار المنطقة.
ليرد الجيش الصيني باجراء تحركات
يا اصحاب العيون الضيقة؟ ومن
حربها الباردة مع امريكا تعود
وتدريبات عسكرية في البحر
والمجال الجوي قرب تايوان ردا
الروم في اقصى شرقي تركيا انه
سيتم الاعلان عن بشرى جديدة
المساعدة. فهل هناك مآرب اخرى
للولايات المتحدة? ورقة تركيا
البلاد والجائحة تتفشى من جديد.
حيث تشهد الصين ارتفاعا كبيرا في
للمساعدة في مواجهة تفشي كورونا
المتزايد لترد برفض قبول
بسبب قانون التفويض الامريكي
الذي يتضمن زيادة المساعدات
العسكرية لتايوان. لتصرح
الخارجية الصينية ان القانون قد
اعربت بكين عن غضبها واستياء
القوي ومعارضتها التامة لواشنطن
سريعة لتايوان وفق رويترز استيقظ
التنين الصيني من نومه. حيث
وبكين. وبعد ان اجاز القانون
الامريكي انفاق عسكريا تبلغ
على انطلاق العملية الروسية بحسب
صحيفة بول ستريت جورنال. الرئيس
امنية تصل قيمتها الى عشرة
مليارات دولار ومبيعات اسلحة
سلاح شدام الذي يحول قنبلة رخيصة
غير موجهة او غبية الى سلاح عالي
النيويورك تايمز وهو ما يمنح
كييف قدرة قصف دقيقة التوجيه لم
واخرى تنتهي لكن هناك حرب من نوع
اخر تدور رحاها بين واشنطن
حتى ذلك الموعد. اليس خير البر
عاجله? الصين الغاضبة. حروب تبدأ
الاوكراني لديه عدة شروط لكن اذا
كانت لديه خطة للسلام لمن انتظار
اوكرانيا. وذلك بتزويد القوات
الاوكرانية بصواريخ الباتريوت
امريكية يا للعجب. في زاوية اخرى
وبوتين يظهر مبتسما ليعلن عن
قواعدها في مهمات تستمر لخمسة
واربعين يوما والحركة بسرعة احدى
الدقة وذلك بواسطة نظام تحديد
المواقع العالمي جي بي اس ليتيح
لها ان تعمل في جميع الاحوال
الجوية وذلك بحسب صحيفة
تكن تمتلكها من قبل. وبعد هذا
كله انه يعتزم تقديم خطة سلام في
الرابع والعشرين من فبراير
المقبل اي بالتزامن مع مرور عام
وعشرين عقدة بحرية فضلا عن انها
مسلحة بست منصات لاطلاق طوربيدات
قيمته ثمانمائة وثمانية وخمسين
مليار دولار تشمل السماح بمساعدة
التي تعد من اكثر انظمة الدفاع
صاروخ كفاءة بالعالم اضافة الى
في تسرب نظام طائراتها الى
المسيرات الايرانية. والتي
تحقيقات بعد ان تصدعت
استخباراتها. وذلك بعد تناثر
اخفاء غواصة يوم القيامة ويشغل
عقول الاستخبارات العالمية
كييف بطائرات يقال انها ايرانية
وهي في الحقيقة تحمل تقنية
من عيار خمسمائة وثلاثة وثلاثين
مليمتر. الرد من واشنطن جاء من
تستخدمها روسيا في حربها ضد
اوكرانيا لتكشف الجهات الامريكية
مستعدون للتفاوض مع كل الاطراف
المعنية حلول مقبولة مضيفا لكن
التسريبات والتي مختصرها ان
روسيا تنوي مصنع خاص على اراضيها
سيرفضونه لانك قد اقتطعت ارضا من
اوكرانيا التي تقدر بمئة وثمانية
لشركات تتخذ امريكا مقرا لها من
اجل التصدير واشنطن تفتح تحقيقا
الى حرب التسريب وبعد الكشف عن
حصول ايران على تقنيات تكنولوجية
الاف كيلومتر مربع. هذه المساحة
هي مساحة لوكسمبرج وهولندا
استخدامه على مجريات الحرب ضد
روسيا. ليعود بوتين ويصرح انهم
الامر يعود لهم لسلا من يرفض
التفاوض لكن هم من يرفضون. نعم
وبلجيكا ومولدوفا مجتمعات.
بالعافية على قلبك ومن المساحات
لدعم اوكرانيا في عام الفين
وثلاثة وعشرين تعتمد سبل
في صفقة مع طهران لانتاج
الطائرات المسيرة. تقصف موسكو
مدينة باخموت لتعلن اوكرانيا
جميع وسائل النقل الكهربائي في
بتدشين غواصة الثقب الاسود. يمكن
لهذه الغواصات العمل بعيدا عن
انها حرب فعليه الاعتراف بالواقع
وسحب جيش من اوكرانيا. يبدو ان
كييف بسبب نقص الكهرباء. هناك
شمرت هولندا عن ساعديها واعلنت
الروسية تعلن عن مقتل ثلاثين
جنديا في اوكرانيا في جبهات
الاوكرانية ان قواتها افشلت
محاولات تسلل لقوات فاجنر الى
خركوف بالشمال الشرقي لاوكرانيا
بينما قالت هيئة الاركان
الاوكرانية. برأيكم من سيضع نقطة
النهاية. هنا وزارة الدفاع
حكومتها عن توفير مبلغ اجمالي
قيمته ملياران ونصف المليار يورو
اسماه التأثير الزائد عن الحد
للقوى الغربية على الشؤون
جهدهم ضمان حصول الجيش الروسي
على جميع الاسلحة والمعدات
المخرج قد قرر ان يكتب الحلقة
الاخيرة من مسلسل الحرب
العالمية. لترد الولايات المتحدة
قائلة ما دام بوتين قد اعترف
اعلن عن اطلاق الحرب قبل عام
تقريبا. وفي ذات السياق طلب
الرئيس الروسي بوتين من رؤساء
شركات تصنيع الاسلحة بذل قصارى
الروسية في اوكرانيا تأتي في
اطار جهد تاريخي لمواجهة ما
بيسكوف ان هناك تقدما كبيرا نحو
نزع السلاح في اوكرانيا وهو احد
العسكرية التي يحتاجها للقتال في
اوكرانيا. وقال بوتين ان الحرب
الاهداف التي اعلنها الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عندما
سادة. الكريملين يعلن عن اقتراب
بوتين من تحقيق حلمه بعد عشرة
الروسية في موسم الاعياد. ليقول
المتحدث باسم الكريملين ديمتري
اشهر من العملية العسكرية في
اوكرانيا وذلك باعلان احراز تقدم
كبير نحو تحقيق اهدافه هناك.
والقدرات الدفاعية الاوكرانية
اجل غير مسمى تقول روسيا عكس ذلك
فالنهاية قد اقتربت. نعم يا
والسبب واشنطن الجيش البريطاني
يعمل في المستشفيات. واردوغان
تقترب من الصفر كما لموسكو فيما
يتوقع زلينسكي زيادة الهجمات
بسبب فلسطين. روسيا تعلن بينما
يعتقد الجميع ان الحرب ستمتد الى
الهاوية والولايات المتحدة تطالب
بالتدخل. بينما بكين تستشيط غضبا
يبشر الشعب التركي بهذا الانجاز
التاريخي. وتشيلي تعارض الغرب
الحرب عن نطاق اوكرانيا؟ فاجعة
صينية تجعل العالم على حافة
امريكا ولاول مرة بسلاح عالي
الدقة يصل الى الاراضي فهل تخرج
تحقق في الامر وبوتين يحرج الغرب
ويكشف عن الثقب الاسود. لترد
يطالب بالسلام. روسيا تحارب
اوكرانيا بسلاح امريكي وامريكا
للحرب الاوكرانية يعلن عن الحلقة
الاخيرة ليكتب المخرج هذه
النهاية الكرملين عملية العسكرية
اوشكت على الانتهاء وزلنسكي
النهاية. برأيكم هل علينا ان
نتفائل